This is a very simple test.
One thing will change in this
photo. And one thing only.
Try to spot the change.
I’ll give you a few seconds to figure it out.
Here’s what changed.
See the clay pots on the table?
They’re brown now. Before, they were grey.
But if you didn’t notice, don’t worry, you’re not
alone. Most people don’t notice what’s right in
front of them. Even if they think they would.
That’s the part I find most interesting. That
people think they’ll notice things that
they actually don’t. You can make changes
that are fairly big, even bigger than the
one you made, and people will miss those.
Psychology professor Dan Simons of the
University of Illinois is famous for his
experiment where people were so busy counting the
times those dressed in white passed a basketball
that they failed to see the
gorilla walk past in plain sight!
Why is it that we fail to see things
that are right in front of us?
Part of it is just we have limits on how
much we can focus on and pay attention to.
If the visible structure of the eye is
like a camera lens, then the retina,
the inner layer of tissue at the back of
the eye, is like the film inside the camera.
This delicate organ forms an image by collecting
light reflected from the surrounding environment.
But within the retina, very little
of it is actually “high-resolution”
consisting of “fovea” that does
complicated tasks like identifying faces.
Most of our vision is low resolution.
So we can’t see everything.
We are bombarded by so many stimuli that
it exceeds the capacity of our brain.
So we ignore most of what we “see”.
If you think the clay pot example was
too subtle, you’re about to see one
of Dr. Simons’ experiments showing an EXTREME
example of how much some of us fail to notice.
An unsuspecting pedestrian is
giving directions to the guy
on the left who is actually one of
the experimenters in this study.
A door passes between them, and the first
experimenter is replaced by someone else.
And the man giving directions has no clue
he’s now talking to a different person!
Eight of the 15 people approached in
the study didn’t know the person they
were talking to was replaced with someone else.
After the change we’ll say hey, did you
notice anything unusual? It’s kind of rude,
they could have gone around us. They really
had no idea they were talking to someone else.
And he says those who did notice the
person changed kept giving directions
anyway because they felt the
social pressure to do that. So,
what are the implications of
change blindness in everyday life?
If you forget who your waiter is, that’s natural.
It would be easier to remember if something
about them sticks out and grabs your attention.
Like if they had blue hair.
Our failure to see change is why we tend
not to notice continuity errors in films.
If you’re patting yourself on the back thinking
you’re great at noticing mistakes in movies,
well, here’s some news for you.
Clip People who notice them are convinced they
always notice them. But of course, they’re
only aware of the ones they happened to notice.
They’re not aware of all the ones they missed!
There’s another more serious real-life
implication of change blindness.
It could explain why eyewitness
testimony may sometimes be unreliable,
leading to a witness wrongly
identifying a suspect.
So, now that you’re more aware of how
unaware you are, time for another test.
You’re about to see two images
switching back and forth rapidly.
Keep your gaze fixed on the center.
And see if you can spot the
difference between them.
So, did you see what changed?
If not, pay attention to the man
on the right wearing the jeans.
But just like before: keep
your gaze on the center so
that only your attention has moved, not your gaze.
Did you catch his jeans changing
color from blue to brown?
Now that you know what’s changing,
you can see the change happening for
yourself because you’re focused on it.
If you don’t focus on what’s changing
you're simply not going to see the change.
How about one more example?
Did you notice what changed this time?
Take a look at the boat on
the right. It has disappeared.
Seeing is difficult. Because we are limited
in our sight, we have to let so much go.
There are some life lessons here, too.
Perhaps what you truly need is in front of you.
But you can’t see it because you’re
focused on something else.
In other words, you may not
have seen what you truly need.
I hope you’ve enjoyed this video.
So does this make you better at detecting
changes? Maybe. Maybe not. For example,
did you notice that my shirt changed
throughout this video?
Leave a comment if you did.
Turns out, you can get away
with a lot more than you think.
Awareness is tricky to improve unless
you know what you’re working for.
But you can improve your brain by building up
skills in math, science, and computer science.
Brilliant is a website and app that makes
learning STEM super fun and interactive
so it doesn’t even feel like learning.
My all-time favorite is their
Logic course to really improve
your critical thinking skills that are
the basis for mathematical reasoning.
In this example, you have to put
the robots in the correct order.
If you’re ever stuck, there are explanations
so you know where you went wrong.
And you can explore the laws of physics
and the principles of engineering
by playing through the scientific thinking course.
There’s something for everyone on Brilliant
- no matter your experience level.
To get started for FREE, visit to
brilliant.org/newsthink or click on
the link in my description or pinned comment. And
the first 200 people to click my link will get 20%
off Brilliant's annual premium subscription
which unlocks all of the courses.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom